the marvel team hasn't stopped working  not even on the already released wanda  vision  the post-credits scene after the finale  episode appears to have some darker  color values overall  as well as many more green and dead  trees in the landscape than were in the  version released in march 2021  it appears dr strange also makes an  appearance in astral form  looking down on wanda's hideaway further  emphasized by the dr strange theme being  part of the credits  one theory is that this could be a clue  towards what we'll see in doctor strange  and the multiverse of madness  or it may be a result of sylvie and loki  messing with the timeline in the loki  series